Speaker 1: All right.
Let's hear from you.
It's time for the Friday feedback of the week
or the Friday feedback.
Someone said it should be called the apple
bags, but that seems a little risque for our
particular setting and audience.
So it is what it is.
But let's start with a very important message
from John McCullough, who said on YouTube,
David Packman drinks Bud Light and it shows.
I'm going to tell you the funniest thing about
this whole Bud Light thing.
Now, for some of you who don't know, Bud Light
is now being subjected to a boycott attempt
by the very people who say you shouldn't do
boycotts because it's a form of cancellation.
Bud Light did a partnership with Dylan Mulvany.
Dylan Mulvany is a trans woman who I had never
heard of until conservatives got all angry
about her.
I don't even know whether we would know who
Dylan Mulvaney is, were it not for right wingers
who were furious.
So after Bud Light did this partnership with
Dylan Mulvaney, many on the right said we
now have to boycott Bud Light.
Now, here's the funny thing.
I've been boycotting Bud Light since I started
drinking alcohol because I think Bud Light
is terrible.
I think it's just disgusting, completely disgusting.
Give me an Allagash White.
Give me a Belgian wheat.
Give me Come on, guys, please.
But I think Bud Light is disgusting.
So when this entire thing happened, I was
able to take the position that I will continue
not having Bud Light for no reason other than
I think it's absolutely disgusting and terrible
beer.
The funny thing is the following before the
Dylan Mulvaney thing, when someone like me
would say Bud Light is terrible, give me a
microbrew, get me whatever the right wingers
would go, Oh, you're CC drink an American
beer, drink bud, drink Coors, drink, whatever.
Now, those very same people say Bud Light
is the one that's for the sissies who support
the trans people, or whatever the case may
be.
I have not had a Bud Light in decades.
I continue not to drink Bud Light, but it
is laughable that that now counts as an insult.
But it just reminds you about the strange
bedfellows and enemies that politics makes
when your brain can be so easily broken.
All right.
Another comment from K Jay about the economy.
CBJ says to me, How's Biden working out for
you, bud?
I'm sure prices of everything are down and
the economy is perfect, right?
Well, I mean, let's talk it through.
Biden's working out fine for me, but I don't
really need anything at this point from the
government.
The question is, what is the economy look
like?
Prices.
When you look at inflation, inflation numbers
are down, down dramatically from where they
were a year ago.
So inflation is slowing down significantly.
The economy is never perfect.
We still have inequality.
We have people who have to work multiple jobs
just like we did under Trump and just like
we did under you know that it's not unique
under Obama.
We had that.
Speaker 3: Obama now.
Speaker 1: Under George W Bush, etc.
But it's hard to find indicators that look
particularly bad.
The stock market is like pretty okay.
Unemployment is at record lows, job creation
is doing well, Inflation's coming down, consumer
confidence is doing well.
A GDP has been on the upswing.
Yeah, you tell me.
I mean, they point to the indicators, tell
me the metrics that show us that everything
is terrible, flawless P wrote in about book
bands and says so when told not to teach from
the Bible as though it were fact is not teacher
being censored unfairly.
Are you banning books?
Ella Mayo Your argument is cringe and useless.
Of course.
Some topics and framing of some topics.
Topics aren't appropriate for public schools.
That's not controversial, I have to admit.
I have no idea whether this person is in favor
or against the book banning that we're seeing
in Florida.
I can't tell.
They say something about the Bible when told
not to teach from the Bible as though it were.
Fact is a teacher being censored unfairly?
Is that banning a book?
No.
Oh, I see the point.
Listen, there's two different things here.
Saying that religious texts have no place
in science class is not banning books.
It's saying this is a science class and religious
texts of any kind have no place here.
It could be the Koran, it could be the Bible,
It could be whatever science.
Geologists read or believe in or the, you
know, the golden tablets of Joseph Smith.
It that's not banning books.
It's saying those books should be in courses
about comparative religion or history of religion.
This is a very confused
per